dove l'ho messa a roma o eccola qua o
porca il tar non funziona più notai e
per favore
ok
salve posso immaginare i vostri dubbi in
questo momento del tipo ma dove sei cosa
cazzo stai facendo della tua vita e
soprattutto perché non ci sono video per
rispondere alla vostra domanda sono
chiuso in un bagno in questo momento
perché il mondo là fuori fa paura e non
voglio andarci guardavo faccio come i
bambini che si chiudono nell'armadio
quando hanno paura non me ne frega
niente perché devono uscire farli a
salire dallo stress dalle paure e dalle
incertezze posso rimanere qui dentro per
sempre e avere tutto ciò di cui ho
bisogno
c'è un sacco di acqua potabile c'è una
ventola che vi permette di respirare
perché dovrei soffrire non ce la posso
fare
su youtube in questo momento si sta
vivendo un periodo di paura perché tutta
sta pagliacciata che abbiamo tirato su
nell'arco di dieci anni sta cadendo come
un castello di carte e sta facendo
uscire fuori dalle persone il loro vero
essere perché la gente lo sa benissimo
che gli youtuber non solo quello che si
vede in video perché quella è soltanto
una pira dell'ata quelle soldato la
maschera e il nostro essere noi stessi e
questo un branco di casa sotto conigli
che non hanno neanche la faccia tosta di
affrontare un problema e siccome gli
youtuber sono persone vere bla bla bla
lo sentimenti come voi lo dovreste
perdere subiti sano siamo tutti tutti
così e io da stoppando non voglio uscire
quel dopo lì che c'è nell'angolo è
diventato il mio migliore amico e non
voglio lasciarlo da solo
viva che vi faccio vedere dove sono
ho preso un nuovo ufficio
[Musica]
benvenuti nell ultima puntata della
prima stagione delle ciò con karim usa
chiedo scusa per l'audio ma come
capirete essendo tutto ancora
completamente vuoto
rimbomba come se fosse una chiesa
sconsacrata dunque di cosa parleremo
oggi è giusto ho paura di rimanere senza
lavoro
ebbene sì tutti su youtube stanno
correndo ai ripari chi si sta cagando
addosso chi sta sbattendo la testa più
volte contro lo spigolo della sua
scrivania di apre un patron ma senza far
vedere la cifra che la gente donà e chi
invece prende direttamente un pezzo di
cartone maestra da scrivendo non ho più
un soldo erano youtuber e quindi oh mio
dio cosa sta succedendo su youtube
lo sapete cosa sta succedendo su youtube
ne avrete sicuramente sentito parlare da
break in italy se non avete vissuto
video ve lo linko in descrizione perché
sicuramente uno dei più esplicativi ma
ne hanno parlato anche quelli sul serve
ne ha parlato chiunque e quindi per
l'amor di dio panico in sala stampa pre
vico in sala stampa
e questa poca lips la potete notare
anche voi dai vostri youtuber preferiti
in cinque semplici fasi la prima cagarsi
addosso la seconda parlare
dell'argomento apocalypse la terza
cagarsi addosso la quarta a correre ai
ripari mettere mille mari avanti e
cercare una soluzione
la quinta chiedere direttamente i soldi
alla gente e io posso capire ogni
singolo comportamento di queste persone
e sai perché perché noi youtuber abbiamo
una data di scadenza
scritta nel retro del nostro culo tutti
dicono che youtube è il trampolino di
lancio per poi fare qualcosa di
grandioso con la tua vita
no sai che cosa youtube youtube è il
quarto d'ora di notorietà moltiplicato
per dieci anni è la cosa più sbagliata
che puoi fare quando è un po di
notorietà e delle entate abbastanza
cospicue e dimenticarti
ogni volta che c'è un problema su
youtube sai cosa succede nella nostra
testa non è mai
cerchiamo di sistemarlo raddoppiamo qui
mettiamo un asse di legno per non far
crollare il muro della nostra vita
no no no no no quello che succede ogni
volta che c'è un piccolissimo problema è
questa voce che si risveglia che sempre
dentro di noi ma si risveglia quando c'è
un problema su youtube che si risveglia
e ti dice olmo prepara la vaselina e
vatti a fare un bel bidet perché te lo
stiamo per mettere nel cu non
dimenticatelo mai mi raccomando voltaici
sua e capisci che la soluzione che la
gente ti dice in modo aggressivo vai a
lavorare negli altiforni in miniera
potranno avere un piccolo fondo di
verità
ma c'è un problema noi non abbiamo un
vero e proprio curriculum c'è quello che
noi facciamo su youtube e un pochino a
noi manco ci prendono negli altiforni
perché non abbiamo esperienza
lui sì che diceva che uscire da un lungo
matrimonio è come uscire di prigione nel
senso che devi ricominciare la tua vita
ecco youtube è la stessa cosa tu devi
uscire da un periodo in cui non hai
fatto effettivamente nulla e quindi ti
devi preparare a trovare un lavoro con
lupo la tua esperienza ma prima che
arrivi il periodo in cui vado a lavare i
piatti in pizzeria perché arriverà sarà
un paio di date di un paio d'anni
arriverà quel momento lì voglio lasciare
qualcosa e da quando ho raggiunto il
milione di iscritti da quando mi è
arrivato a casa il mega gold button di
youtube per ringraziarmi del milione di
iscritti che io ho deciso che su youtube
voglio prima lasciare qualcosa a
lasciare un'impronta
ed è per questo che ho fatto leggermente
meno video ma più mirati nel senso che i
video che io ho nel canale che piacciano
o non piacciano perché ce ne sono tanti
di tanti tipi sono comunque memorabili
nel senso tutti i ricordi qual è il
video che non ti è piaciuto qual è il
video che ti è piaciuto di più di cosa
parlano
video di cosa succede sul mio canale lo
sai non sono tre video al giorno di cui
nessuno glie ne sbatte un cazzo
e questo video come dicevo all'inizio e
il finale vero perché io ho fatto una
specie di mid season finale al senso che
l'ansia di era finita a metà della prima
stagione dello show con quel video lidl
dell'ufficio e questa invece è proprio
il finale è vero e proprio della prima
stagione e la seconda stagione inizia da
qui ho detto come se fosse una puntata
di è domenica papà
da qui come vedete ho deciso di fare
questo video qui per farvi vedere che
ancora c'è del lavoro da fare e questo è
quello che volevo dirvi non tanto a voi
tra l'altro pubblico che sapete molto
meglio di noi che noi non dureremo
ancora tanto tempo ma soprattutto per
ricordarlo a me stesso e dirlo ai miei
colleghi youtuber content creator che
siano sul web che fra qualche anno ci
toccherà fare una piccola riunione di
condominio per decidere le sorti della
nostra vita
[Musica]